Maryland police are looking for a man  caught on video violently confronting  three young people that were putting up  fliers in support of George Floyd watch  this walkway hey this disturbing  incident happened Monday at the Capitol  Crescent Trail in Bethesda just outside  Washington you can see the suspect  ripping the fliers and a roll of tape  away from one of the victims the man  appears then to threaten the person  recording the video and rams him with  his bike before shouting at him to take  down the sign scale really disturbing  very disturbing upsetting several people  sent me that video yesterday Vlad I'm so  glad you're showing it because  somebody's gonna recognize his hat his  little bike shorts his sunglasses it's  very frightening for those young people  so I hope that they I hope somebody  gives him a call